you said that your wife Lila has very
expensive taste does this ever bother
you if she was like Alex I want to buy a
$50,000 purse you'd be like for Alex
it's pennies you wouldn't care no she
does she does whatever she wants Leila
wanted to have nice things her whole
life and so we have the ability to do
that like what do I gain by depriving
her it's not like it puts us in any kind
of different financial situation than we
are now like if her spending in any way
materially affected our goals she
wouldn't do it I mean I spend money on
like gym equipment so we just bought the
old UFC headquarters so that'll probably
cost like 450 Grand all in how many
square feet was that it was like 12,000
square feet something it's three floors
of 12 it's 36 36,000 Square F feet W 12
12 12